en turquie l'aéroport d'antalya pour la
famille giroud passait des vacances tous
ensemble dans ce pays
c'est une grande première bonjour j'ai
des bons joueurs car il y a encore
quelques heures
yves marie leurs deux enfants capucine 7
ans et gaspard six ans était encore dans
la banlieue de lyon
cette année ils vont passer une semaine
au bord de la mer dans ce pays qu'ils ne
connaissent pas encore
à bord du bus la découverte commence ça
semble bien
voilà il fait
on a reçu la même
on attend à briser la voir de plus près
avec impatience leurs vacances ils vont
les passer dans cet hôtel club de plus
de 1000 chambres
première surprise pas de barrière de la
langue
la famille girouette accueilli en
français est ici
l'hôtel est tellement grand que mary
yves et leur enfant doit faire une
sacrée trotte avant d'arriver à leur
chambre
vu la taille de l'établissement
il espère profiter d'un logement
spacieux pour toute la semaine sauf
qu'en arrivant dans la chambre eelv est
un peu déçu on a essayé de prendre une
option suite volontairement pour être
vraiment dans un cocon familial
là pour le coup c'est respecter là aussi
cette semaine ils vont devoir oublier
leur intimité
parents et enfants vont dormir tous
ensemble dans cette petite pièce d'à
peine 20 mètres carrés on est loin de ce
que le prospectus du tour operator leur
laissait espérer sans chambre familiale
spacieuse avec chambres + salon sans
préciser que cette année il n'y en
aurait pas pour tous les vacanciers
il faut dire que la turquie a été prise
d'assaut par des millions de touristes
en quelques semaines seulement
et tous ces vacanciers comme les giroud
n'avait pas du tout prévu de débarquer
sur les plages turc eelv et marie l'an
passé était parti en tunisie même s'il
ressemble à celle de tunisie
ah oui largement air derrière meilleure
que celle d'un modèle top 6 cette année
légère ou passent leurs vacances ici
comme 400 mille autres français c'est
que des événements imprévus ont
bouleversé la géopolitique du tourisme
en méditerranée
et voilà ce qui a tout changé
des révolutions en tunisie et en egypte
une guerre en libye et un attentat
sanglant au maroc
au total quatre millions de touristes
européens déboussolé que les autres pays
de la région se sont empressés de
récupérer et à ce petit jeu la turquie
et la grande gagnante
le pays a prévu d'accueillir plus d'un
million de vacanciers en plus en
quelques mois du jamais vu auparavant
et pourtant ce pays a des ressources
insoupçonnées
plus de 8000 kilomètres de côtes des
hôtels hors norme à l' architecture
délirante et des paysages à couper le
souffle
alors la turquie va-t-elle être à la
hauteur de cette arrivée massive de
nouveaux touristes qui vont être les
grands gagnants de cette ruée vers ce
pays
enquête sur la dernière destination
soleil en gogh à un peu plus de trois
heures de paris
en chemise bleue à droite
voici florian vighier le directeur
général du premier tour opérateurs
français
depuis quelques mois il doit compenser
les pertes qu'il a subies au maghreb
cent mille clients en moins et c'est ici
en turquie qu'il doit t'on recaser la
moitié ce jour là il a rendez vous avec
mais m le responsable du club où
séjournent notre petite famille un hôtel
dans lequel florian loup toutes les
chambres et il est un peu tendue car il
veut que tout soit prêt il va faire
attention au moindre détail pâture des
lumières c'est à dire que c'est éclairé
l'année
donc éventuellement tu as des clients
qui peuvent venir sur les pontons mac os
à mon avis la nuit on aurait plutôt
fermé l'accès parce que sait jamais ce
qui peut arriver on est au dessus de la
mer ce que florian veut c'est aussi que
ses clients se sentent comme à la maison
un jour qu'on fait le tri sélectif
maintenant contre un peu le temps de
traduire en français encore oui je veux
voir le fait de plastique on comprend ça
pour le reste du tirage au sort
la plupart de nos clients parlent
essentiellement français certains
anglais mais très peu turc d'imaginer et
pour ces touristes français question
nourriture aussi florian a tout prévu à
ses pattes avec sa place à la mode le
haut du pain pour les français c'est
important
la baguette faut qu'il se sente dans un
pays exotique mais quand même garder des
choses delà de la maison sale et ça les
rassure c c'est les français sont pas
les très grands voyageurs voilà grâce à
ce genre de détails
florian vighier a rempli son hôtel toute
la saison 2000 vacanciers vont tisser
journée chaque semaine retour avec la
famille giroud dans le même club
ils vont enfin profiter du soleil de
turquie c'est quoi la première source
généralement que vous vous aimez faire
quand vous arrivez sur votre lieu de
vacances
beignets principalement c'est ce qu'on
va essayer de faire ce matin voilà si la
mer est trop froide l'on tentera la
piscine pour ce séjour d'une semaine ils
ont payé 600 euros par personne et cela
peut grimper jusqu'à 1000 au coeur de
l'été par un gain on est proche de la
mer et à boire et à manger là bas et
pour ce tarif
ils peuvent se servir à volonté au bar
il n'ya rien à payer pour ses boissons
des forfaits tout compris voient la
boisson et nourriture en turquie comme
en tunisie
il y à des forfaits tout compris et pour
yves en cas de petites envies de manger
local
tout est prévu l'hôtelier français a
fait venir des cuisinières turc
ça c'est super bon c'est les galettes et
qu'il faut avec des farc avec du riz
soit de la viande sont un mélange
c'est super bon c'est super bien j'en
prends exceptionnelle et qui est là
depuis ce matin pour les préparer je
serais incapable de même non par
contrainte du plat qu'on mange ça re
étape par étape peut-être par étage de
fort wayne c'est par état des gueuses
des mets au fromage ou à la viande
c est inclus dans le forfait mais il ya
aussi dans le club des tentations qui
peuvent faire dépenser plus yves et son
vieux copain réginald qui a rejoint sur
place notre petite famille sont des fans
de jet ski et ça tombe bien le club a
pensé à tout y est
y'a pas de problème du jet ski c'est 40
euros en plus dans les poches du groupe
écoutez je crois qu'il fera carreau un
quart d'heure par personnel
ce petit plaisir dans les vagues va
faire grimper le budget familial des
forfaits tout compris avec quelques
extras la formule aurait été la même en
tunisie
alors
mais ici le forfait est à 600 euros
contre 500 là bas alors au bout d'une
semaine
quel est le bilan pour les gir où il ya
des activités pour les enfants c'est
bien l'encadrer c'est ce qu'ont cherché
aussi maintenant voilà 100 euros plus
cher par personne et ça commence à faire
un certain budget là et qu'il est pas
alors forcément justifiée par rapport à
la tunisie la turquie un peu plus cher
que la tunisie cette année
cela n'empêche pas les touristes
d'arriver en cascade et cela peut poser
de sacrés problèmes aux professionnels
retour avec florian vighier le patron du
tour-opérateur français pour accueillir
tous ces vacanciers qui n'était pas
prévue en début de saison il a dû
relever un défi de taille trouvé pour
eux des places supplémentaires dans
d'autres hôtels
bonjour comment allez vous bon joueur
soyez le bienvenu merci beaucoup ici
florian à négocier pour ses clients une
centaine de chambres avec le directeur à
peine un cinquième de l'établissement
contrairement au club de la famille
giroux il n'est donc pas vraiment ici
chez lui
florian ne peut pas imposer sa formule
destinée exclusivement aux français
inspection du buffet cette fois pas de
baguette et aucun plat typique de
turquie
du fait c'est beaucoup plus
internationale avec poulet pané ces
choses qui conviennent au bout de mes
clients européens quasiment non c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué on présente dans
cet hôtel environ 15 à 20 % de ma
clientèle
on ne peut pas demander d'avoir des
buffets spécifiquement pour nos clients
ou les pannes et mais aussi les
saucisses et pizzas cela ne correspond
plus vraiment au cahier des charges du
tour operator mais les touristes
français de florian sont en minorité
dans l'hôtel alors là rien n'est inscrit
dans notre langue
pourtant florian vighier fait payer à
ses clients le même prix que dans son
premier hôtel plus de 600 euros pour une
prestation inférieure et vous allez le
voir il ne s'en cache pas c'était le
seul moyen pour lui de compenser ces
pertes de tunisie sur la turquie nous
avons par client une marge qui est un
peu plus importante puisque les prix
sont plus élevés et donc en termes de
marges
on se rattrape sur la turquie et par
rapport à la tunisie le rapport ça peu
près de clients en turquie permet de
rattraper la marge de trois clients en
tunisie
donc on devrait à peu près un organe se
rattraper devrions nous rattraper son
actionnaire
cette saison en turquie vous trouverez
donc très peu de promotion
les vacanciers français dans ce pays
vont permettre aux tour-opérateurs de
sauver leurs marges des français à
l'assaut de la turquie car ici le
potentiel touristique est énorme pour
pouvoir en profiter
certains n'ont pas hésité à investir des
sommes pharaoniques et afin d'attirer
notamment une clientèle richissime venus
du monde entier
ils ont construit des hôtels qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs en
méditerranée
des complexes touristiques gigantesque
qu'on s'attendrait plutôt à trouver à
las vegas ce bâtiment vous dit sans
doute quelque chose
bienvenue à l'hôtel kremlin une
reproduction de la célèbre résidence des
tsars et les dirigeants de l'ex urss
un petit air de russie en turquie cela
peut paraître étonnant mais ici cet
hôtel cartonne auprès des touristes
russes comme yelena venu tout droit de
moscou le kremlin
c'est à moscou donc ici je me sens un
peu comme à la maison
vous avez vrai chez vous oui c'est vrai
mais vous savez c'est pas tous les jours
que j'ai l'occasion de me rendre à
nantes et pris la place rouge en carton
pâte et un peu plus loin voici un autre
monument célèbre la basilique saint marc
à l'hôtel venise c'est même toute la
place du même nom qui a été reproduite
avec sa tour et même une chambre
nuptiale à son sommet encore plus
surprenant les vacanciers peuvent aussi
logés à l'hôtel concorde comme l'avion
reconnaissable à son fameux nez une idée
saugrenue mais ici on joue sur la
nostalgie du supersonique qui ne vole
plus depuis son crash en 2000 à quelques
encablures à un autre hôtel catastrophe
le titanic référence au célèbre paquebot
et à son naufrage
celui qui a créé tous ces édifices
extravagant c'est hassan semaine un
architecte turc
il a fait fortune en imaginant ses
hôtels à thèmes au titanic il a surfé
sur le succès planétaire du film avec
leonardo dicaprio dans la région hassan
est devenu un roi du marketing car
l'établissement affiche complet pour
séduire les touristes l'hôtel a
carrément demandé à son personnel de
s'habiller aux couleurs du paquebot je
vais vous raconter quelque chose
le chantier avait commencé le premier et
le deuxième étage était déjà construit
et puis les propriétaires ont dit
le titanic est un paquebot qui a coulé
et si on fait un hôtel avec ce nom ça
risque de porter malheur un moment ils
ont presque penser changer le nom de
l'établissement
l'hôtel titanic un complexe sur 5
hectares et si hassan souk men ne
construit que des établissements
gigantesque ce n'est pas uniquement à
cause de sa folie d'architectes c'est
aussi parce que le littoral n'est pas
protégé l'état autorise presque toutes
les constructions et même les encourage
vous savez le terrain est attribuée par
l'état et les terrains attribués par
l'état en avantage ici pas d'être très
grand et surtout il n'y a presque rien à
payer
c'est quasiment gratuit car l'état
bradley terrain pour aider au
développement du tourisme des terrains
de l'état octroyée pour 49 ans en
échange les autorités se rattrape en
prenant environ 5% des bénéfices de
l'établissement alors avec de telles
facilités de construction
notre architecte est un peu devenu le
roi du monde et pour faire entrer
toujours plus d'argent dans les caisses
a sense of men a créé en pleine
méditerranée
un joyau sa plus grande fierté c'est ce
palace comme il n'en existe qu'une
poignée à travers le monde
bonjour comment allez vous je vais bien
merci
l'homme qui l'accueille ce jour là c'est
cetin
le manager du lieu le propriétaire lui
ne vient qu'une fois par an c'est un
oligarque russe l'une des plus grandes
fortunes du monde il n'a pas hésité à
sortir son carnet de chèques pour
figurer dans le livre des records
les 6es bosphore c'est plus grande
piscine de la plus grande piscine
d'europe
vingt-quatre mille mètres carrés
l'équivalent de 20 piscines olympiques
de quoi faire quelques belles longueurs
une piscine censé représenter le
bosphore qui traverse la ville
d'istanbul avec sa rive européenne et sa
rive asiatique hassan travaille sur des
hôtels toujours plus grand c'est ce qui
fait grimper sa rémunération
en fait nous sommes payés au mètre carré
je travaille sur une très grande surface
alors je gagne plus d'argent donc pour
nous c'est le nombre de mètres carrés
qui compte
rien qu'ici pour 17 hectares à san soc
man aurait empoché près d'un million et
demi d'euros
quant au coût de cet hôtel de 600
chambres où il ya même de l'europe la
faune il est de plus d'un milliard
d'euros
l'architecte a utilisé cet argent pour
attirer les plus grosses fortunes grâce
à des espaces comme ce spa réservé aux
riches
parmi les riches
à partir de cette partie est totalement
privée et ça coûte combien ici pour une
journée ces dix mille euros c'est avec
ses services qu'il compte rentabiliser
leur projet pharaonique est le produit
qui pourrait leur rapporter le plus
c'est cette incroyable suite royale 600
m² 600 m 2 chambres 1 seulement
ah oui une suite ou notre architecte a
décidé d'en mettre plein la vue
même dans les endroits les plus
inattendus ici aussi salle de bains deux
enfants aussi toutes les armatures de
doha or ou vides et alors
c'est ici aussi ça le poubelle même le
papier de toilette
cette suite est facturé 15000 euros par
nuit de piscine en terrasse de quoi
rentabiliser l'investissement du
propriétaire en quatre ans grâce à ces
hôtels hors norme
les nouvelles fortunes d'antalya ont
fait de la riviera turque un haut lieu
du tourisme balnéaire mondiale mais
depuis quelques années c'est une autre
région de turquie qui attire de nouveaux
conquistadors la cappadoce
c'est incroyable paysage lunaire façonné
par les volcans ont fait la fortune de
professionnels qui ont tout misé ici il
y a quelques années
ses cheminées de fées sculpté par
l'érosion des cendres c'est le nouveau
trésor de la turquie il attire des
milliers de touristes en mal de grands
espaces
marina et gersende sont parisiennes pour
leur petite escapade en cappadoce
elles ont décidé de dormir dans des
lieux qui en ce moment font fureur sur
internet
il y a quelque chose qui leur a tout de
suite plu le propriétaire est français
les chambres de son hôtel ont été
directement creusé dans la roche que ça
les photos grâce à ces chambres
troglodytes
l'établissement affiche complet il y a
quatre mille ans les habitants avaient
creusé ici de véritables cités
souterraines pour se protéger des
envahisseurs arabes et perses
aujourd'hui ces grottes les
investisseurs se les arrachent et dans
la région
c'est un autre français qui a pris
plusieurs longueurs d'avancé sur tout le
monde
avec son chapeau de paille voici jacques
avizou dans le village d'outils sarr il
al'allure d'un touriste en goguette
mais c'est un investisseur visionnaire
au cours d'un séjour il ya 20 ans il est
tombé amoureux de la cappadoce et de ses
paysages lunaires
je m'étais dit jamais je n'aurais
l'occasion d'aller sur la lune mais j'y
suis et j'ai dit robin ans que j'ai fait
le voyage d'aller je fais pas subi de
retour alors pour pouvoir rester sur la
lune
cet architecte venue d'albi dans le
sud-ouest se bâtit une maison dans une
ancienne habitations troglodytes et il
s'aperçoit très vite du potentiel
touristique de ces logements atypiques
il se lance alors dans les maisons
d'hôtes pour vendre des moments uniques
on doit ressentir les souvenirs oubliés
du ventre de sa mère c'est une sorte de
cocon c'est un cocon ouvert sur un
paysage de rêve aussi cette expérience
jacques avizou l'avant très cher aux
touristes qui se pressent 7-6 7/1
bédanne breakfast
c'est un 180 euros la nuit grâce à sa
trouvaille
jacques avizou s'est enrichie très vite
des maisons d'autres comme celle ci il
en possède une vingtaine qu'il loue
jusqu'à 400 euros la nuit jacques est
devenu l'un des nouveaux rois de la
cappadoce
c'est difficile à croire mais voici à
quoi ressemble et ses maisons d'hôtes
plutôt chic
il y a vingt ans des ruines qui à
l'époque n'était pas protégée par les
autorités turques et que personne ne se
souciait de réhabiliter un bâtiment
complètement en ruines
un bâtiment à moitié en ruine comme ça
tout était comme ça tout tout tout y
avait hier ayant iam qui étaient
habitables en tout cas il a fallu tout
faire ces ruines
l'architecte les retape une par une au
départ il investit 150 mille euros à
l'époque il est tout seul à penser que
le troglodyte va cartonner auprès des
touristes couvrir comme ou encore le
café chez toi si tu veux sur la terrasse
aujourd'hui jacques est une des
personnalités du village d'outils sar
mais quand il est arrivé personne ne le
prenaient au sérieux
on dit des lits en turc des dit jacques
jacquelot fou je peux le confirmer parce
que je les entends du oui exactement
personne n'avait imaginé qu'il puisse y
avoir un avenir dans ce que je faisais
et maintenant on est obligé de constater
le résultat là quand même
on a travaillé on est récompensé et pour
aménager ces maisons d'hôtes jacques
n'hésite pas à s'aventurer dans des
lieux où les touristes ne risque pas
d'aller ce matin il se rend à dix
kilomètres de là dans cette bâtisse à
moitié démolie
cette dame au foulard c'est la
propriétaire d'une caverne d'ali baba
inattendue jacques vient ici faire la
chasse aux bonnes affaires qui vont
faire grimper la valeur de ces locations
aux robinets de bronze
voyez il ya plein de trucs ins et des
coffres des coffres des coffres de
l'année janet des coffres mais ça de
temps en temps c'est intéressant de
trouver un joli motif
rien d'extraordinaire aujourd'hui on est
enfin céder il continue pourtant à
fouiller car ces meubles ou objets
entassés
non pas qu'une valeur historique
maintenant ils vont ils vont me demander
50 euros là peut-être parce qu'avant
c'était c'était 2 euros car dans la
région tout le monde le sait jacques un
bisou à gagner beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent mais cette fortune il n'aime
pas trop en parler quand vous êtes
arrivé ce type de bien ça s'achète
combien un maximum de dix mille euros
maximum et aujourd'hui des ruines comme
ça ça se peut se répondent entre les
mains
parlons d'autre chose pas de pas de sous
pas pour moi je suis heureux d'être
riches mais les pauvres qui m'ont vendu
il pourrait avoir quelques rancoeurs par
son parent ne semble pas selon nos
estimations
jacques serait à la tête d'un patrimoine
immobilier de près de 10 millions
d'euros
alors aujourd'hui transformer des ruines
troglodytes en hôtel tout le monde y
pense
au volant de sa voiture voici l'un des
émules de jacques à bisous mourad cool
tour un turc qui a grandi en france en
ce moment il fait des kilomètres pour
trouver ces fameuses pépites des ruines
troglodytes
il dispose d'un solide capital trois
cent mille euros qu'il veut investir
dans cet autre village durée mais
c'était intéressant en fait c c'est le
coeur du tourisme donc cessé qu'en fait
le genre est bien investi leurs
emplettes
je vais voir s'il est là le propriétaire
c'est l'amener avec ses amis line sali
le propriétaire c'est ce vieil homme né
dans le village bien avant le
développement du tourisme
moore a tant entendu dire qu'il avait un
bien à vendre une maison familiale
abandonné qu'il a reçu de son père en
héritage et à peine à l'intérieur
mourad va être immédiatement séduit par
ce terrain vague qui ne paye pas de mine
car une fois en haut on peut admirer
tout ce qui fait le charme de la
cappadoce on voit les cheminées devant
nos lacets c'est ça c'est c'est quelque
chose que les clients recherchent
beaucoup en fait c'est la vue l'ouïe la
vue et le parking l'aca contraire là
c'est très succinct fois que je montre
aux devant lui sinon mais c'est après ça
augmente après il y a de quoi faire au
moins cinq chambres troglodytes
mais certains défauts pourrait rebuter
beaucoup d'acheteurs
las apprendre l'humilité en fait il faut
boucher en fait de l'extérieur de l'eau
mourad voit tout de même un gros
potentiel dans cette vieille maison
troglodyte en ruines il se verrait bien
en propriétaires d'hôtels c'est
magnifique c'est un très joli en or et
c'est mais au moment de conclure
mourad va tomber de haut hc alors
combien tu veux pour ta maison
maldonado écoute réfléchi les fourrages
de l'avant pour cinq cent mille euros
maintenant il vient il m'a dit si tu
nous donnes 500000 euros il dit je te
vends oui mais j'ai dit cinq cent mille
euros c'est
ça les vaut pas des voitures est ce que
c'est vraiment à mon avis si je ne
pourrai être propriétaire deux cent
mille euros d en noir n'achètera pas
aujourd'hui le vieil homme lui est sûr
de trouver preneur même à ce prix là à
l'image de la cappadoce
la turquie n'a pas encore révélé tous
ses secrets aux touristes cet été ils
seront des millions à faire le bonheur
de ces nouveaux conquistadors